This is what's known as the Feejee mermaid.
What we know from museum documentation
is that Moses Kimball had in his
possession a mermaid that he obtained
from a Boston sea captain. The Boston sea
captain, according to the story, had
purchased it from some Japanese sailors
who said that it was an actual mermaid.
The Boston sea captain brings the mermaid
back to Boston, dies penniless, gives it
to his son who then sells it to Kimble.
Kimble then contacts his friend PT
Barnum and Barnum then loans the mermaid
from Kimball to put it on display as an
actual mermaid.
It's not an actual
mermaid, that much is clear.
We know that it's put together from
various bits and pieces; it's part fish, most
likely carp, there's some bone in there,
possibly monkey bone, but we know that a
lot of it is paper mache. There's an
armature inside, so it's a bit of
everything put together to make what you
see here.
We have this particular object
on display at "All the World is Here"
because it speaks to early museums'
early collecting practices, which were a
combination of scientific natural
history and the spectacle. And this
clearly is a spectacle.